never be this young is the current
single from Lukas Regas new album code
the track is a vibrant mix of pop house
and R&B
the teen star from Berlin spoke to us
about why his latest work meant so much
to him
I was a hundred percent myself of this
album I was right in the thick of the
process I was the one deciding what was
Lucas riga sings about topics close to a
teenager's heart growing up being love
sick and everything that goes with it
the 18 year old sees himself as an
ambassador for his generation he's often
criticized of making meaningless
bubblegum pop but as the son of a music
teacher that doesn't go down well these
are leaves a problem it's wrong to say I
have no life experiences of course I
have less than older people but even at
ten you've experienced things or at
eighteen like me in this period at age
14 he took part in a talent show but
didn't make it to the finals still he
persevered and used online platforms
like YouTube to make covers and live
streams from his bedroom he wanted to
become famous
I'll be needing
the oldest social media fan social media
fans were my greatest gift that's how I
got my first fanbase social media got me
where I am today
spin his online following group click by
click until one day he was spotted by a
big record label from letter near
Hannover Lukas passed up on a high
school diploma to produce his debut
album in Los Angeles in 2016 compass
made the top 5 in the German charts
[Music]
and he's had to get used to attention
wherever Lucas goes screaming fans will
follow
that's an autograph signing in 2016 in
the German town of Ulm fans became so
hysterical there were several injuries
and emergency services were called to
the scene Lucas hasn't only made a
splash on the pop music scene his
biography de Lucas riga code was number
one bestseller of the german publication
- speakers
[Music]
he's going on tour with his new album at
the end of February and eventually wants
to spread his music to other countries
Kamiya Sathya my goal is the plays of
big arenas in germany and in other
countries like France Poland and one day
America America
his ultimate dream is a gig in New
York's Madison Square Garden already a
pop star and internet sensation at 18
years old his dream gig might not be
that far off
[Music]
you
[Music]